Okay,
whoever put me on reddit out there,
you know I got a bone to pick with you
that the plan was to get subscribers at
a torturously slow incremental,
right over a period of decades.
That was the plan.
God,
some people,
you know what all I can say to you,
it's coffee on a Tuesday and Vlog 42,
so there's a feeling I sometimes get.
Maybe you get it to.
That happens.
For example,
when I come around a corner and all of a
sudden I'm confronted by a sunset or at
that moment in a movie when everything
just falls into place,
hairs stand up on the back of my neck
and it chill,
runs down my shoulders,
times it freezes me in place,
blanks my mind,
and the feeling I have is one of
astonishment.
And Jimmy Stewart,
my favorite actor,
describes it like this.
Creating moments in movies.
This I think is the important thing.
Nobody knows exactly how it happened.
Turns out there's a name for this
feeling.
It's called freezer.
It's a French word for cold chill,
but really there is no English
equivalent in French.
It's pronounced like this free zone.
You can have free song with a person,
someone you're attracted to,
and if I had to guess,
it probably happens most frequently in
that nervous,
flirtatious,
almost unbearable time before any
feelings are expressed outright.
Okay,
so have you ever spent a subway ride or
a bus ride?
Sort of on off looking at someone from
across the train,
someone who is beautiful,
someone who strikes you and who you
stupidly fall in love with,
with the 10 minutes it takes to get from
30 Fourth Street to Union Square.
You look at them as they look away and
then you can feel their eyes on you as
you look away,
and then you sort of just wait there
until you think it's safe to know this.
I contacted freezing,
freezing,
freezing.
Maybe it's just me.
Whatever triggers it.
We all get these feelings of freedom.
One of the most common sources is music.
A study published last year in nature.
Neuroscience showed that the moment in
your favorite song when you experienced
that chill,
that feeling of free zone coincides with
the release of the neurotransmitter
dopamine into your brain opening.
Makes you feel good and it's commonly
released to reinforce or motivate
biologically significant activity like
eating or sex,
suggesting that for some reason unknown
to us,
music is inextricably linked to our
deepest reward systems,
but there's something else.
See,
I also get a feeling of free when
overwhelmed by a sad song.
It's a chill,
but a kind of consoling David here on a
professor at Ohio State University and
who runs the cognitive and systematic
musicology laboratory.
Awesome name has this to say about Sam
when a person is in a sad state,
uh,
this hormone called Prolactin is
released and it has a psychological
effect,
a consoling psychological effect.
It's as though the music has put them
into a kind of sham state of sadness.
And the body has responded by releasing
this hormone called Prolactin.
And it's,
it's like mother nature sort of wrapping
our arms around you and consoling you
and saying there are there.
Everything's Okay and you have this kind
of warm,
fuzzy feeling.
Extremely interesting.
But following from that,
I want to pick up on an earlier point
biologically,
we really don't know why music affects
us so powerfully.
White gives us those feelings of Friesen
or constellation or combination of both,
but psychologically I think that music
is embedded in each one of us uniquely
strong along our memories in the way
that Christmas lights are strung along a
tree branch.
To me,
music is the raw or of beauty.
It goes deeper and affects them more
potent emotional response than any other
art form.
It's why when people ask,
I say that the Beatles or the artists of
any medium that have had the largest
single influence on me on February
fourth,
2008,
NASA transmitted a song for the first
time into deep space,
the Beatles across the universe in the
direction of the star Polaris,
431 light years from Earth.
It's always been a sad song for me,
if not for its swelling,
drifting quality.
Then because it gets me thinking of John
Lennon and d,
The idea of melodies like that dancing
out into a silent and unfeeling universe
gives me such a chill and then such a
warmth that I do have the feeling of
being wrapped in a blanket and I'm
consoled for a moment or a minute of my
humanity.
Welcome to everybody who's new.
I'm so glad to have you.
Really.
This is a good example of sort of what
goes on here.
The vlog is a is a project of,
of learning,
but also of expression of trying to say
something a thoughtfully and precisely.
So on my channel page you can find
social networks,
things,
twitter,
tumblr,
facebook,
things like that.
And seriously,
thank you to that person who put me on
Reddit.
I owe you a beer or 20,000.